[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
team-based racing seems to be quite the
fad at the moment with the likes of uber
softs the crew and Sony's drive Club
taking a stab at it
but Slightly Mad Studios is doing things
a little differently with its upcoming
team-based race of world of speed
described as a racing MMO by the studio
not only is it trying to create an
online experience to rival the likes of
shooters and mmo's but it's also giving
the way for three that's right when
world of speed hits PC later this year
it'll be entirely free to download
naturally they'll be microtransactions
involved that lets you buy upgrades for
your car and potentially speed up your
progress through the game but Slightly
Mad Studios is adamant that they've got
the balance right and players that don't
purchase anything won't feel hard done
by all the content will be accessible to
all players regardless of whether they
purchase anything as for the MMO part of
world of speed don't get your hopes up
for an open-world epic this is a street
and circuit based racer albeit one that
has a focus on team-based events and
competition the idea is that players
will be able to create and join clubs
with others and that for every event
they take part in points are awarded to
their club world the speed is throwing
all sorts of incentives into the mix to
keep players from trying to go it alone
for one a podium finish isn't the only
way to earn experience points performing
tricks and drifts during a race will
rack up the XP as well performing
defensive blocks on the opposition in
order to secure safe passage for a
teammate it'll be interesting to see
just how many players will be willing to
take a backseat though indeed the laps I
took around the visually impressive
circuits weren't quite the chummy drives
I'd envisage with each member of the
team tending to just go for a podium
place with little regard for their team
members progress this was a simple
circuit race event though and while
little was revealed of other race types
I did catch a tantalizing glimpse of
Destruction Derby during a presentation
slide perhaps those other modes will
encourage better teamwork as for the
racing itself world of speed leans very
much towards the arcade it was little
trouble to sling a car around a hairpin
Bend at speed or indulge in some wildly
ambitious drifts without careering
headfirst in
we'll wolf while a nitro boost proved
useful listen mean-spirited ramming I'd
love to say that it was all tremendous
fun but the racing felt more serviceable
than it did stimulating hopefully the
final game will feature more in the way
of clear interesting objectives than the
early demo did still one world of racing
does launch players can expect plenty of
improvements post-release that other
aspect of free-to-play games the
constant stream of updates and fixes is
how the studio envisages the game
evolving in the future it's a big
promise attached to a similarly big
free-to-play gamble ultimately world of
speed is a game that's attempting while
so many others have tried and failed to
do to make a racing game of the long
life and community of a top shooter or
MMO that's a mighty big task and one
that's gonna need more than just some
shiny cars and striking tracks the
Slightly Mad Studios team has definitely
got the right idea
let's just hope there's more substance
to his grand ambitions when we see it in
action before its release later this
year
[Music]